Part of what's been fun about
collaborating on the mandalorian with
Lucasfilm and Disney is that we have
been able to see through a few technical
innovations and a few firsts that I
think you're going to have a lot of
impact on the way television and movies
are made moving forward in partnership
with ILM and epic we have put together a
system whereby which we can have game
engine real-time render and video wall
technology coming together to create a
backdrop for the big beautiful world of
Star Wars.
The volume is 21 feet tall
it's 75 feet in diameter run by seven
machines
pumping the visuals onto the screen
that's that's being created in
pre-production and can be on the screen
within 24 hours of being final.
It's incredibly impressive when you first
walk out there because it completely
surrounds your peripheral vision and you
really quickly forget that you're
indoors and you're not out on some
planet surface it feels like a real
three-dimensional environment
surrounding you because it is a
three-dimensional environment.
You can allow your key creatives to all make
decisions together so that the shots are
captured entirely in camera which allows
for a better performance.
And what was so
exciting about this is by bringing those
people together things started to click
and we started to realize well let's not
just do green-screen interactive light
if we're gonna design the whole set and
game engine ahead of time maybe we could
have some in-camera effects if you look
at visual effects heavy films you've got
a film set and then it's gonna go to
post and it's gonna get the world put in
here we're considering all of that at
the same time and how do we create a
background and foreground that live
together on the volume harmoniously.
When we started to play with the idea of
using Unreal Engine for virtual
production that's one of the things that
Richard and John started to embrace is
that you've got this very dynamic world
where you can have randomization of
things and find the happy accident that
gives you the perfect shot being able to
see the actors point at things and see
what they're looking at was pretty
transformative it gave everybody context
with the added benefit
that if you want to move a mountain from
there to there you can do it instantly.
You could switch between the Iceland
location to the desert location all
within the same day of shooting
The ability to shoot a 10-hour dawn is
extraordinary to shoot any sequence
where you say oh this world's not quite
right let's just move it over a little
an extraordinary number of benefits
and advantages for shooting in that
environment it's mind-blowing what that
tool is.
Shots of character in a vehicle
traveling through a complex environment
it's always very difficult to do
believably on stage LED screens are a
wonderful solution to that problem
because what you're doing is you're
taking this technique of image based
lighting that we've been using in
computer graphics for years but it use
it to light a subject.
And then we would do shoots
where we would texture map
real, lit surfaces on to our game engine
geo. And so the camera could move
anywhere we would do interiors like
Werner Herzog's office,
And then you started doing things like building
sets into it having half a spaceship with
reflective surfaces and so it became
exciting because by the end of the
season it was like let's start designing
sets around what this could do well.
Just like the good old days.
It's really a game changer for filmmaking
Welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my video for the mandalorian
season 2 there's a whole bunch of stuff
they revealed recently there's actually
some good news even though everyone's on
quarantine right now so if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos we'll do a giveaway for
Disney Plus memberships all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your biggest theory about mandalorian
season 2 on the video so obviously this
is mostly behind the scenes than showing
how they make the mandalorian series
what's changed about that since the
season 1 episodes the current quarantine
thankfully will not affect the
mandalorian season 2 release date it's
still coming out in October this year
the reason why we're getting it earlier
is just because of the way they're
structuring all the Disney Plus
programming later this year with all the
big Marvel shows that are coming they
finished filming the mandalorian season
2 finale before the big quarantine
started thankfully there are a couple
Marvel series that went on break Falcon
and Winter Soldier and Wandavision are
still tuning up some of their final
episodes but they'll come back in a
couple weeks finish their episodes and
release later this year it won't be that
bad for them the big things about the
mandalorian season 2 they confirm baby
Yoda is mail for everyone that was
wondering he is a little boy I had a lot
of people asking during season one that
were just confused I think people just
didn't watch season 1 with subtitles
because there were actually scenes
during episode 3 where dr. purging
refers to baby Yoda as he gendering him
mail please don't hurt him if it wasn't
for me he'd already be dead so hopefully
that clears up some of that confusion
Giancarlo Esposito was also talking more
about the dark saber lightsaber battles
that he had during season 2 he said he
had crazy lightsaber battles he didn't
say who these lightsaber battles were
with but because they're looking for
other Jedi to help baby Yoda presumably
they'll find more rogue Jedi that
survived the purge I already did a whole
video for a special comic-con panel he
did earlier this year for the
mandalorian season 2 story talking about
everything so I'll link that at the end
of this is really cool the new stuff
that he talked about recently wasn't too
different from the stuff that I talked
about during that other video they also
released this preview of the gomorian
guard that's going to be featured during
season 2
I know a lot of people saw this and
they're like wait a minute are they
going back to Tatooine is this meant to
imply that we're going to be seeing
Jabba's palace in some way because he
employs a lot of gomorian guards that's
not necessarily what this means it just
means that there will become more Ian's
showing up during season two remember
there were jobless on multiple different
planets
so just because they went back to
Tatooine and then in a separate episode
we saw a jobless and crawler on a
different planet with a bunch of jawas
doesn't necessarily mean that they'll be
retreading all this old original trilogy
ground they'll just be a lot of original
trilogy easter eggs and references if
you remember the series takes place
after the events of Return of the Jedi
and Jabba was killed by Princess Leia
during Return of the Jedi so technically
Jabba isn't even around even though
someone like Jabba son or someone from
his family may have taken over all of
his assets the really cool thing that
they get into during this video about
how they make the Mandalorian is the
revolutionary stagecraft that they use
those special led walls it's sort of
like filming an episode on a holodeck or
a really primitive holodeck because they
project the environment and it Maps
around the room in real time synched
with the actors movements Jon Favreau
said that when they were filming
episodes what happened during season 1
is because it was a brand-new technology
a lot of the time they would just try
different things and figure out how they
could use this new tech with each new
episode so by the time they got into the
finale they'd found much clever ways to
use it to make episodes look even cooler
which they then poured into their season
2 episodes so a lot of season 1 was them
just figuring out how they were going to
film episodes as you see them filming
there are a couple different versions of
baby Yoda that they use in episodes
depending on what kind of scene it is
and what they need him to do this is a
scene of them filming baby Yoda for
season 2 and as you can tell this is the
full-blown puppet version of the
character the way that Yoda during the
original trilogy was just a really
complex puppet operated by Frank Oz and
a couple other people the other versions
of baby Yoda that they've used in
episodes are a combination of special
effects and a live puppetry lesser
versions of this version really good
example of a full CG baby Yoda is when
he's using crazy force powers like when
he's forced choking Cara Doon here is
very noticeable that he's a totally
different looking version than just a
minute later in the next scene when the
Mandalorian
picks him up telling him to stop choking
her and they go back to filming with the
regular puppet right after they finished
releasing the mandalorian season 1
episode 8 finale last year there was a
report that the baby Yoda puppet cost
them around five million dollars to make
the actors here Jason sudakis from
Saturday Night Live and Adam pally that
played the incompetent scout troopers
said that because they had to punch baby
Yoda in their scene they were asked to
chill out a little bit by Jon Favreau
who got really nervous after they
punched baby Yoda too hard for fear of
breaking the puppet the reason why
they're saying baby Yoda cost five
million dollars to make is just because
of how complex the puppet is it has to
be able to hold up on screen at 4k and
articulate as if it was a real creature
it's also one-of-a-kind it's not like
they had a baby version of the original
Yoda puppet to copy before they made
baby Yoda so some of that five million
dollars that they're reporting is
probably the cost of them figuring out
what he was going to look like in
development and alternate versions that
they tried along the way so hopefully
they'll release some more
behind-the-scenes featurettes and
teasers for season two if they do I will
totally do a video for it or if you have
a special request obviously things are
going to be really crazy for the next
couple of weeks so if you have special
requests for videos just let me know in
the comments I will still be doing
regular videos like I would for
everything else for the most part
television is unaffected
it's just that movie releases in
theaters that have been postponed
temporarily but I know everyone's hoping
that they'll release Black Widow on
Disney Plus I'm not expecting them to do
that but if we do hear any news about
what's going on I'll totally do an
update video as long as you have alerts
enable for my channel you should see
those videos when I post them every one
click here for that other big
Mandalorian season two teaser video and
click here for that brand new Marvel
phase for spider-man 3 movie
announcement thank you so much for
watching everyone stays safe I'll see
you guys tonight!